he inspired a nation during a difficult
time
but captain tom moore fundraising hero
has died of covert 19.
in april 2020 a then obscure retired
army captain captured hearts
when he attempted to walk a 100 laps of
his garden at the time
of his 100th birthday he wanted to raise
one and a half thousand dollars for the
national health service
instead he raised 43 million and his
story
went global his optimism was contagious
well what can you do i mean
i think assad i'm because i
always be optimistic whatever you're
talking about be optimistic because it's
a good day
i mean things will get better a book
about his life
followed and a film is in the making
queen elizabeth came out of lockdown to
give him a knighthood
and he entered the guinness book of
world records
captain tom served in india and burma
during the second world war
he likened the fight against covert to a
battle with doctors and nurses on the
front line
the prime minister paid tribute to him
when news broke he was in hospital
all i can say is captain tom moore has
been an inspiration to
everybody in this country uh during this
pandemic and i think
our thoughts and our prayers are now
with him and
and with his family despite being
prioritized for vaccination
he developed pneumonia before he could
be protected against the virus
an emblem of hope during the pandemic he
will be mourned by a nation